well it's coming up to noon with a
minute's silence being held across the
uk
to remember those who've died of covert
during the last year
[Music]
[Music]
microphones on
[Music]
well a moment simon's there as the
nation marks the anniversary of the
first national lockdown pausing
to remember all those who died during
the pandemic
this guy's lisa dowd is in solihull for
us one of the places that we saw
uh marking that moment lisa at one place
in the uk that has marked it but of
course
these are losses that have been felt
across the uk
in the last 12 months aren't they
yes all of the uh staff came out here
and they've had quite a year they have
been
helping patients at the end of their
lives
both with covid and without and they all
came out to
reflect what an incredible year it has
been
for everybody and also thinking about
not only the patients they've lost
449 at this particular hospice
but also the families they've left
behind and the children
involved in that as well and i'm joined
now by julie
who is a young person's counselor aren't
you
um julie when you were standing
and reflecting then what was going
through your mind
yeah it's it's it's really just the
tremendous
emotional impact that the pandemic has
had on the children young people over
the last
12 months and their families
especially it's been difficult for all
children but especially for children who
have lost
a parent a grandparent or a significant
person
because ordinarily this place wouldn't
be that quiet would it you would have
perhaps children
scootering around on bicycles and here
to see
perhaps a parent or a loved one who is
at the end of their life so how
different
is this place at the moment yes that's
right the hospice has been a very
different place for the last 12 months
we've had to restrict the amount of
visitors
that can come into to the hospice so
that includes
um children accessing our counselling
service
and just and normal children visiting so
um it has had an impact on on
the staff here we rely heavily on
um the buzz of the atmosphere um
our volunteers haven't been allowed to
come in either which has been a huge
loss to the
the service as well and how of the
children that you've cancelled this
year coped in this extraordinary
situation
how have they co coped sorry even
um we've had different
scenarios children have their own unique
way of dealing with grief
some children have really struggled with
lockdown
especially when there's been a death in
the family they haven't had that extra
support from
um extended family or their friendships
or
school um and they've really struggled
with that
whereas we have had children who have
actually um
really excelled during lockdown because
they've had the protection and security
of their immediate
family and that's actually really helped
been helpful for them the idea of this
day of reflection is that perhaps it
will become an
annual day particularly important i
guess that
for children absolutely absolutely i
mean that one of the key things
the key work we do with children is
memory making
so to be able to remember their loved
one
on an ongoing basis is really healthy
and a really
therapeutic thing for children to have
okay thank you for joining us um julian
you'll see that julie has the yellow
daffodil
of the marie curie at charity as all the
staff
were wearing earlier a symbol of hope
for the future that's also something
uppermost
in the staff's mind here hope for the
future
and also looking ahead to this evening
where there will be a further period of
reflection
at eight o'clock this evening where it's
hoped that people will come out onto
their doorsteps and perhaps
light a candle or shine a torch to to
light up the night sky
as we reflect on what an extraordinary
year it has been
for everybody